[Music]
the story always starts the same way on
the side of the road in a backyard or in
a parking lot a large dog hovers over a
dead animal quietly eating as you
approach the dog looks up its eyes
shining in the Dark As you move closer
the dog stands up on its hind legs it's
well over seven feet tall it has the
body of a man but the head of a dog or a
wolf some call them werewolves others
call them dogmen whatever they are
they've been terrifying people for
hundreds of years in the past it's been
easy to dismiss these sightings as
mistakes were superstitions but these
creatures are not so easy to dismiss
anymore because now we have pictures
foreign
19th century and perhaps even before
there have been stories of a terrifying
creature lurking in the dark woods of
Northern Michigan it looks like a large
black dog but then it rears up on its
hind legs and stands over seven feet
tall it has the head of a canine with
icy blue eyes that Shimmer in the dark
it has the body of a man covered in fur
it howls like a wolf though the sound
has been said to be closer to a scream
than a how these stories existed as part
of a myth that circulated around
Michigan and Wisconsin for years but the
myth went mainstream in 1987. Jack
O'Malley and Steve Cook worked at wtcm
radio in Michigan as part of an April
Fool's Day prank they wrote a song
called the legend the legend tells the
story of a race of half human half dog
hybrids that appear every 10 years and
stalk through the dark woods of Northern
Michigan the song warned listeners that
these dogmen were due to appear this
year and then the song ended ominously
and somewhere in the North Woods
Darkness a creature walks up right
the best advice you may ever get
is don't go out at night the reaction
cook in O'Malley got was unexpected they
were hoping to have fun and spook the
listeners a little bit then the phone
lines lit up the first call was from an
elderly man who said he was chilled to
the Bone when he heard the song because
he had seen a similar creature several
years earlier and that opened the
floodgates calls began pouring in with
people telling their own stories about
encounters with the dog man the legend
went back over a hundred years in 1887
Lumberjacks in the area came across what
they thought was a large dog until it
stood up screeched at them and ran into
the woods in 1857 a letter described a
frightening creature that stood up like
a man that bore the face of a gray wolf
a French fur Trader's diary was found
dated 1804 in it he described seeing a
loop Guru the French word for werewolf
even Native American legends talk about
a shape-shifter a man who could
transform into a wolf there's
documentation of an actual Sheriff's
investigation responding to a local
sighting of a dog man still these were
all stories but now that the legend of
the dog man was front and center in the
Public's mind more reliable Witnesses
would come forward and they would bring
proof
in 1961 a night Watchman was working his
shift at a factory near the haymarsh in
Michigan one of the job perks was the
Watchman and his family could live on a
house on the property the front porch of
the house made it easy for him to keep
an eye on things The Watchmen made his
rounds and headed back to the porch to
sit relax and have a cup of coffee this
was a remote area and the night was
passing unevently the sound of crickets
and night birds filled the air then just
after 3 A.M The Crickets and birds
suddenly stopped there was only silence
it was so abrupt that the Watchmen
started to feel uneasy then at the edge
of the property he heard the distinctive
sound of a chain-link fence rattling at
this late hour in such a remote location
this wasn't an accident this was an
intruder The Watchman drew his gun and
waited then he noticed that the Intruder
wasn't a man it was something much
bigger he said it appeared to be covered
in brown gray hair it was tall and had
broad shoulders it alternated between
walking on four legs and then standing
up on two it was looking for something
in the driveway the Watchman quietly
went into his house and grabbed a Kodak
Signet 35 millimeter camera as the
Watchmen stepped back onto his porch the
creature walked slowly along the
driveway directly under the lights the
Watchman adjusted the camera for long
exposure and held it as still as he
possibly could and took this picture
I ran the image through AI to enhance it
after this photo was taken the creature
went back down on all fours and walked
out into the woods though he wouldn't
explain why until years later the
Watchman didn't let his children play
outside after dark another story
happened in 1987 in Sparta
is
Sparta I knew that was coming hey I'm
reliable Sparta Michigan 1987 just a few
miles north of Grand Rapids two young
men were heading to a cabin for a
weekend of hunting and fishing they were
on a secluded road with no lights so it
was very dark about a hundred yards
ahead the car's headlights caught
something that made both men jump it
looked like a human covered in Gray fur
as they drove closer and then passed
they got a good look at it it was the
size of a tall man it stood on two legs
had a wolf-like face and was covered in
Gray fur it even raised its arms and
starred at them as they drove by Reed
City Michigan 1993. Courtney was
sneaking a cigarette behind her parents
home when she saw movement near a barn
that was on the property about 50 feet
from the barn she saw what looked like a
large dog or wolf but couldn't really
tell what it was then it turned around
looked at her and stood up on two legs
it was over six feet tall covered in
dark fur and had a dog-like face with
long nose and pointed ears and there
would be more sightings over the years
in the same area 1994 in Watersmeet 2001
in Alpena and all Witnesses reported the
same creature face of a canine that
stood on two legs and was over six or
seven feet tall bigger than any dog or
wolf but nobody really knew how big the
creature was until 2007 when an
eyewitness took a picture of its
footprint
now for a strange story out of rural
Coffee County residents there say
they've heard unusual animal sounds at
night and several ATV writers say
they've seen unusual looking creatures
in the distance I can just say this
something's going on in the woods
recently the two men have received
reports from ATV riders of distant
sightings of an unusual animal but it
didn't sound like a coyote hey there's
something strange there's some knocking
going on we hear some screeches they're
not dogs they're not coyotes and this is
not the first time there have been
reports of an unusual creature in the
woods
the witness of this next sighting is a
prominent Michigan politician and wants
to remain anonymous in 2007 he was
driving from benzonia to Traverse City
he was taking the scenic route down
Cinder Road a few miles outside the town
of benden in the distance he saw a pair
of eyes shining in the dark and at first
he thought it was a deer but as he got
closer he realized it was too big to be
a deer as he approached he slowed down
to 30 miles an hour and was about 200
feet from the creature which didn't move
he described it as a large wolf up on
two legs standing near a dead deer it
was well over six feet tall and covered
in dark fur at that point still a good
distance away he stopped the car to take
a look it didn't move so he thought it
could be a giant stuffed animal someone
playing a joke it wasn't a joke was it
nope before he could finish his next
thought the creature dropped down on all
four legs sprinted across the road and
disappeared into the woods the man was
frozen in his seat for a full minute
before he sung the courage to
investigate he grabbed his flashlight
and approached the dead deer there was
no way he was going to follow the thing
into the woods but he wanted to see if
it left any tracks it did the man was
familiar with animal tracks and said it
looked like a wolf print but was bigger
than any wolf print he'd ever seen
luckily he had his digital camera with
him he dropped the shotgun shell in the
print for size reference a shotgun shell
is between two and three inches long
depending on the gauge and the load so
this footprint could be 10 or 12 inches
long maybe bigger when interviewed the
man said he was familiar with the song
on the radio and the local Legend but
always thought they were just
entertaining stories after this incident
he realized the story is real and he
never drove on that road again
[Music]
this is a strange-like human-like Park
creature seen in Texas so that's at the
Amarillo Zoo and they came across this
weird image while looking at some
security footage recently it was
captured in the middle of the night it
was back in May in the City of Amarillo
wants your help and identify
most Michigan Dogman sightings happen in
Michigan oh do they that's some quality
investigative journalism right there
shut up but this particular Cryptid has
the ability to cross state lines just to
the west of Northern Michigan is
Wisconsin this area also densely wooded
has its own local Legend that's awfully
similar to the Michigan dog man and it's
called The Beast of Bray Road in the
1990s residents of Walworth County
reported seeing a humanoid werewolf
stalking a road outside of town it's
described as being between six and seven
feet tall covered in dark fur with a
head resembling a wolf or a bear and
it's been seen moving on two legs and on
four the creature was covered in
newspapers in books documentaries even
TV shows there were so many reports
about the Beast that local reporter
Linda Godfrey was assigned to cover the
story now at first she was skeptical but
later she believed the Witnesses were
telling the truth what makes this
Cryptid different than the Michigan dog
man is its aggression Doris Gibson was
driving along Bray late one night when
she felt a thump thinking she hit
something she got out to investigate
then the Beast leapt out of the darkness
and chased her back to her car then it
scraped the trunk of her car leaving
deep scratch marks before she drove away
and many of these sightings would have
been just part of a hazy Legend if not
for a Linda Godfrey's reporting in 2018
this blurry photo was taken by Danny
Morgan just outside Elkhorn Wisconsin
he said he saw the creature not once but
twice in a month Morgan said it was over
seven feet tall brown and hairy and
walked out toward the road picked
something up and then went back into the
woods now I don't know if the creature
in this picture is seven feet tall it
looks more like a corgi man yeah it's
blurry and hard to tell but whatever it
is I'd be terrified if I saw that thing
walking along the side of the road at
night in July of 2020 there were two
other sightings of the creature about
nine miles east of Elkhorn again the
same description at least seven feet
tall walking on hind legs covered in
dark fur and the sightings go on and on
some from very reliable sources when I
first heard about it I I probably
laughed I think I did laugh because it
just seemed crazy to me that anybody
would would think that but then when you
go and talk to the people and you meet
them and they still seem genuinely
frightened they don't want to see it
again you know you just can't help but
believe somebody like that I've
interviewed people with with two phds
middle-aged women who work in a factory
on third shift at night very elderly
people Farmers somebody from the
Milwaukee airport with a very high
clearance it's just men women you name
it there's there's no one sort of person
Linda Godfrey started out as a skeptic
but ended up publishing a few books
about dog men werewolves and the Beast
of Bray Road one of them is ominously
titled I know what I saw the most
compelling and frightening piece of
evidence comes from the Gable film The
Gable film was discovered in 2007 in a
box of junk that was sold at a yard sale
it looks like it shot on eight
millimeter film sometime in the 70s it's
the typical home movie kids playing in
the snow dad chopping wood fixing his
car then the film takes an ominous turn
there are shots of the photographer
scanning the woods for something though
it's difficult to see there are shots of
the dog who seems excited by something
and appears to have caught a scent then
we're back in the woods
a photographer scanning the trees again
and then stops on this it seems to be an
animal on all fours but I can't tell
what kind of animal
then it starts walking then it starts
running
the photographer takes off and then
seems to fall down one of the last
frames captured by the Gable film is a
mouthful of teeth and then Darkness
I told my mom I thought I saw a werewolf
and my mom believe me I was walking
along a good probably seven to ten
seconds before it had turned its head
that thing that was no dog that was too
big to be a doc that thing was bigger
than me
that thing was stalking cornfields
jumping on cars and feasting on roadkill
for two years people in Elkhorn
Wisconsin whispered about a king-sized
creature who roamed Bray Road
in the 19th and early 20th centuries
circuses often had Sideshow performers
called Freaks and one of the most
popular attractions would be the bearded
lady or the dog-faced boy or the human
werewolf these were otherwise normal
people but covered in hair from head to
toe and even though they were considered
freaks they were really just regular
people with a condition called
hypertrichosis hypertrichosis is a
condition usually caused by a genetic
mutation that causes hair to grow all
over the body I've got a cousin with a
unibrow different affliction
typically hair grows everywhere but not
on the palms of the hands or soles of
the feet so a person really can look
like an actual Wolf Man wolf person
don't do that we
signal anymore nah that's that's going
away no thank God it was getting old the
first recorded case of hypertrichosis is
Petrus Gonzalez he was actually a
European nobleman who attended Court in
several countries during the mid 16th
century and he acted like a perfect
nobleman and by all accounts his
children several of whom also had
hypertrichosis were well educated
talented and kind still they were not
considered fully human Gonzalez's
marriage to Lady Catherine is considered
the inspiration for the fairy tale
Beauty and the Beast A Tale As Old As
Time
a song is old is rhyme
Beauty and
the Beast
never let a Disney song go to waste now
I'll admit that a human who looks like a
wolf is unsettling but you know what's
worse than a human who looks like a wolf
a human that acts like a wolf
[Music]
the word lycanthropy comes from King
lichen of Arcadia in one telling of the
legend Lycan wanted to test if Zeus was
really an all-knowing God so lichen
served Zeus the Flesh of lichen's own
son Zeus was all knowing and he wasn't
pleased with the meal no no did you feel
like one of those comment Cuts nope Zeus
killed all of lichen's children all 49
of them the boy that was sacrificed was
brought back to life and lichen was
transformed into a wolf whoa that's
worse than a one star review on GrubHub
way worse
clinical lycanthropy is the condition
where a human believes that they are
part dog or part wolf
oh it happens and it could be awful in
2012 Rudy Eugene was cruising the back
streets of Miami at some point he gets
out of his car and attacks a homeless
man named Ronald Papo Eugene strips off
all of his clothes and starts beating
Papo until he can't move Eugene then
jumps on popo and begins eating his face
and this goes on for 18 minutes before
police respond now the entire event is
covered by a security camera and I won't
put that video here but if you really
want to see it you don't I'll put a link
below so when police finally arrive they
command Rudy Eugene to get off poppo but
all he does is turn around and snarl
police shoot him five times and he dies
at the scene and the aftermath is
gruesome 75 percent of Ronald papo's
face was chewed off he lost an eye his
nose and most of his cheeks it took
months of surgery to restore Papa's face
but he was still left disfigured and
blind it was assumed that that Eugene
had taken bath salts which are said to
make people act this way but toxicology
reports showed only Trace Amounts of THC
it's like he just snapped and because
Eugene died at the scene we don't know
his motive but another case happened a
few years later that could give us some
Clues
when 19 year old Austin haruf came back
from college in the summer of 2016
something was off about him he was
constantly ranting and screaming he
moved his bed into the garage because he
thought the house was full of demons he
would pace around the house at night
knocking on the bedroom doors of his
family letting them know that they were
safe from the demons because he was on
patrol oh I don't like any of this at
all oh this is the fun happy part of the
story oh boy Austin's family assumed he
was on drugs but the only evidence they
had was his strange Behavior one day in
August Austin was having dinner with his
family he got angry and stormed out of
the restaurant nobody expected what
would happen next haruf's mother had a
bad feeling and made a call to the
police I don't know how to do this my
son he's um taken off it seems like he's
a little delusional after leaving the
restaurant Austin walked four miles and
found his way to the home of John
Stevens and his wife Michelle Michonne
Michelle was relaxing in the garage
chatting with neighbors as she often did
John was out walking the dog across the
street neighbor Jeffrey Fisher heard a
loud scream he ran out of his house and
saw Austin haruf aggressively
confronting Michelle Jeff immediately
starts running to help Austin then slams
Michelle onto the ground and starts
beating her savagely Jeff grabs Austin
throws him to the ground and thinks that
the situation is over it's not as Jeff
was catching his breath he starts
feeling pain and warmth and wet all over
his body Austin had a knife when the two
men were struggling Jeff was cut all
over his body badly and what's worse
Austin is now getting up off the ground
and coming at him with a knife so Jeff
runs back home locks his door and calls
9-1-1 as Jeff is waiting for the police
to arrive he hears from across the
street someone's snarling and another
person screaming when the police finally
get there they see a man on his back who
turned out to be Michelle's husband John
John's eyes were wide open and he looked
like he was in shock he just kept saying
help me please help me as the police
Drew their guns and tasers they saw what
was happening Austin was jamming his
fingers into John's mouth tearing out
pieces of Flesh and eating them while
growling like an animal and there were
chunks of Flesh all over the driveway
this this was a mess so the police tased
Austin they kick him over and over and
over again and it wasn't having any
effect Austin would stop for a second
and then go back to eating John's face a
canine unit showed up with a dog and
even with the dog attacking him Austin
would keep trying to go after John's
face but then Austin finally looked up
at the police and snarled at them while
yelling please kill me I'm eating people
it took five of them but the police were
finally able to subdue Austin John and
Michelle died in their driveway and
again it was assumed that Austin was on
a drug like bath salts or flaca but once
again the only drug found in his system
was a small amount of THC later Austin
would recount what happened but his
Story made no sense it involved demons
and witches and dark figures in the
shadows Philip Resnick a psychiatrist
was brought in to assess Austin's mental
state in his 38-page report Resnick
believed Austin was suffering from
Clinical lycanthropy in other words he
thought he was a werewolf
stories about dog men and werewolves
exist in every culture and go back to
the beginnings of those cultures and
it's easy to see why there are actual
physical and mental conditions that can
make humans look and act like wolves but
what about the sightings unfortunately
the only photos we have are blurry and
most of them are hoaxes the Gable film
is amazing but that's also a hoax when
Mike agrusa heard Steve Cook's song The
Legend he thought it would be fun to
create a mini horror film to go along
with the story agrusa contacted cook
they partnered up and distributed the
film on the internet and of course it
took off and when I started working on
this episode I wasn't a Believer if you
heard my live stream you know I don't
like to cover Cryptids because there's
so little physical and photographic
evidence we're stuck having to take the
word of eyewitnesses who often seem
questionable trust me bro right but when
journalists like Linda Godfrey go from
Cryptid skeptic to Cryptid believer I
reevaluate my position and when sheriffs
and deputies put their careers and
reputations on the line by filling out
official reports about werewolves I
re-evaluate my position I still think
most of these stories are mistakes or
false memories or flat-out hoaxes but
not all of them can be explained and for
me personally that's my favorite way to
end an episode of the y-files is by
reevaluating my position being ready to
believe something new so if you're that
night Watchman or that farmer or small
town Deputy who has a picture on his
phone that you can't explain and you're
afraid to send it anywhere
send it to me I'm ready to believe
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything today do me a favor
like subscribe comment share
I know but it really helps the channel
and like most topics we cover on the
channel today's topic was a
recommendation from the last live stream
so if there's a story you'd like to see
or learn more about go to the yfiles.com
tips I can't do all the stories but I
read all the submissions and special
thanks to our patrons who make this
channel possible I'm amazed by your
generosity and I am grateful for your
support and if you'd like to support the
Y files consider becoming a member on
patreon or grabbing something from the
Wi-Fi store
did Heckle fish underwear there yet not
yet yeah that's too bad you can be a
spicy meatball that's one way to
describe it anyway that's gonna do it
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you are appreciated
[Music]
oh